foreign
the country's new leadership lineup in a
twice a decade reshuffle
powerful seven-member polygurus standing
committee is led by sea the others
include Shanghai Chief lisao former
anti-graft star jaladi
former party Secretariat Chief
walghuning Beijing party secretary
taitzi these Chief of Staff Ting suiciao
and Guangdong leader Lisi
this final lineup has been beyond many
analysts most extreme predictions as it
marks a clear break from the collective
Leadership Model that's underpinned
China's rise it's also a historic moment
because it breaks so many Norms from
term limits to early retirement to age
Norms to female representation as well
as the resume prerequisite for example
Shanghai Chief Lite who is likely to
become China's next Premier does not
have National governance experience and
for the first time in a quarter Century
China won't have a woman sitting on its
current 24-member poly Bureau marking a
major step back in gender representation
what these powerful men have in common
is that they've shown the utmost loyalty
to Steve and his signature policy
critics worried though that the move
could present new risks from lack of
opposing voices
foreign